Drei Punkte liegen zwischen Tabellenplatz 2 und Tabellenplatz 11 in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Jedes Wochenende ist fröhliches Tabellenspringen angesagt und mittendrin dabei die SV Elversberg. Der SSV Jahn Regensburg hat damit als Tabellenletzter jetzt nicht so ganz viel mit zu tun, aber über diese beiden Vereine und die Lage der Liga spreche ich jetzt mit SVE-Fan Jonas Nickolai und Jahn-Blogger Thomas Süß. Viel Spaß.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gebühl.
Alexander Schur!
Wir haben seit Jahren ein Problem in der Offensive. Nicht nur erst seit diesem Jahr. Als wir noch Andreas Albers hatten, hatten wir zwar Tore, aber jetzt nicht diese Weltantoren. Da sind wir aber wieder bei dem Punkt. Für manche Spieler ist vielleicht die 2. Liga entweder das Limit oder sie sind halt noch nicht so weit. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja ein paar gute Stimmen. Also in Noah Garners hat er Anlagen. Eine Leosuth ist schon irgendwo eine verlässliche Bank. Auch wenn man mit der Autorin mich jetzt auf den Kopf abschlägt. Wer aus der Orotak-Bo hat gute Ansätze in Kai Pröger, gute Ansätze in Christian Kühfeldt, der ist unglaublich erfahren. Aber jetzt beim Spieler wieder gegen Braunschweig, du hast halt einfach immer noch, es gibt immer noch das gute Pech. Das gibt es halt einfach auch noch. Und dann aus welchem Grund auch immer sehr falsche Entscheidungen getroffen. Der Kopf ist vielleicht nicht ganz da. Es ist vielleicht am Ende Qualitätsfrage. Und dann muss halt die Mannschaft schauen, dass sie das auf die Straße bringt. Also ich will da nicht einzelne Spieler rauspicken. Die Kritik sind, das steht mir nicht zu, weil ich auch selber nie Fußball gespielt habe. Und B, ich mich natürlich als Zuschauer leichter redet. Sondern, ja, steht mal rüber, dann passt das schon. Aber es ist einfach Fakt, dass wir unglaubliche Probleme in der Offensive haben. Das haben wir seit Jahren. Deshalb haben wir natürlich diesmal noch Probleme in der Verteidigung dazu bekommen. Auf den Außenverteidigern ganz speziell. Da hat man ja auch schon mal das Thema. Das kann man sicherlich unserem Sportverstand angreifen. Da kommen wir wahrscheinlich auch noch dazu. Aber ja, um auf das nochmal zu kommen, du hast es ja so schön gesagt, ich habe das positive versucht vorzugeben, aber mir ist schon durchaus klar, dass wir sehr viel Negatives haben. Bei fünf Torschützen wäre gut, wenn wir 15 Tore hätten und nicht fünf.
Ja.
Und vor allem nicht bei 33 Gegentoren. Bei 33 Gegentoren möchte ich nur eine Sache sagen, und das ist auch etwas, was beim Trainerwechsel schon klar geworden ist. Er hat es geschafft, das mehr zu stabilisieren. Nichtsdestotrotz haben wir immer noch Fehler drin. Wir haben natürlich Glück, dass einer unserer Jugendspieler brutal durch die Decke geht. Also Pauli Wurm hätte ich fast ein Denkmal gebaut, wenn er so nur ein Tor geschossen hätte. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das halt so ein… Du musst sagen, du hast beim Jahr nicht ein großes Problem, du hast überall so Probleme. Du musst halt versuchen, eins nach dem anderen anzugehen. Und das ist halt für einen Fan, glaube ich, sehr schwer zu ertragen. Weil du willst natürlich gern sehen, dass die Abwehr steht, dass wir geile Flanken schlagen und am besten nur drei Wuden. Aber das geht nicht.
Ja, und es ist natürlich… Also es ergibt natürlich auch total Sinn, dass man jetzt erstmal Minimum bis zur Winterpause sagt, wir stabilisieren erstmal die Abwehr und dann gucken wir weiter. Weil man hat einfach diesen Kredit mit diesen 33 Gegendoren. Die kriegst du ja nicht durch, wenn du fünf Spiele mal keins kriegst, dann werden die ja nie weniger. Sondern das ist natürlich einfach gleichbleibend. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber so, du kannst ja nicht beides… Also meistens kannst du gerade, wenn du in dieser Position bist, du kannst nicht beides gleichzeitig machen. Du kannst nicht sagen, wir stabilisieren jetzt die Defensive und wir gucken jetzt, dass unsere Offensive pro Spiel doch drei Tore mehr schießt als der Gegner. So ungefähr.
Du musst…
Funktioniert nicht. Alles gut. Und das, ich meine, man muss dann auch sagen, es sind jetzt auch drei Spiele bis zur Winterpause. So und dann ist aber, glaube ich, auch da wieder super wichtig, was passiert denn in der Winterpause? Hat man überhaupt irgendwie die finanziellen Möglichkeiten? Aber ehrlich gesagt doch einfach sowieso, wie agiert man auf dem Transfermarkt? Und du hast es schon angesprochen, wie sieht da denn die Situation gerade aus, sowohl finanziell als auch vom Sporvorstand her?
Finanziell will ich nicht sagen, aber deutscher Meister wird nur der Jan. Wir sind eins hinter Bayern. Also ich meine, das ist auch, wenn ihr mal einen Köln-Fan zu Gast habt, die Arbeit auch von Christian Köhler mit gewesen und seinem damaligen Prokuristen Philipp Hausner, die wahnsinnige Arbeit geleistet haben. Wir sind unglaublich gesund. Wir haben positives Eigenkapital. Aber um da mal einen schönen Vergleich heranzuziehen, wie sollst du die Dinge, also bei, wenn ich jetzt sage, Hansa Rostock, dass die nicht viel Geld haben, obwohl sie die Nummer 1 in ihrem Bundesland sind, wenn man dann sagt, McPom mit ihrer Struktur oben, ist ja nicht so verwunderlich. So und jetzt bist du bei uns in Bayern, wo du ewig viel Konkurrenz hast. Also und die Oberpfalz ist halt schon jetzt nicht strukturschwach, aber woher soll das ganze Geld kommen? Und ich meine, für welchen Sponsor, Investor, WM, ich meine, wir haben nicht ohne Grund Netto. Netto ist originalerweise aus Regensburg. Und also von den Finanzen, das würde schon gut ausschauen, aber in der heutigen Zeit vom Profifußball, wo alles unbundlich viel Geld kostet, kannst du das schon kaufen, dann gefährdest du halt wieder alles. Dann bist du eben mit einem Ding, wo du sagst, wir können jetzt schon für Millionen Spieler kaufen, dann muss halt unser NLZ länger warten. Jetzt was ist denn wichtiger für einen Jahn? Einen guten Spieler zu kaufen, ein NLZ. Wo willst du auf lange Sicht hin? Welche Vision hast du nicht? Ich denke, als Jahn Regensburg muss man sich da schon klar sein, dass wir die Nummer 5, 6 in Bayern wahrscheinlich sind und dass wir da gar nicht die Ansprüche haben sollten, fertige Spieler zu kaufen oder auch einen fertigen Trainer. Ich meine, natürlich gäbe es mega interessante Trainerkandidaten, sei es Steffen Baumgart, Zorniger und Co., aber ich denke, Steffen Baumgart verdient so viel, wie uns der Sponsor im Jahr zahlt. Also wie sollen wir sowas holen? Und darum musst du halt schauen, was du machst. Und ich denke, mit einer Laie werden wir gut beraten. Vielleicht findet sich aber auch eine günstige, gute Alternative. Zum Transfermarkt genommen an sich, das ist eine große Kritik an unserem neuen Sportchef und auch in Bayerlötze, dass er nicht gut geplant hat. Ich meine, wir haben verletzungsanfällige Spieler, Robin Siegele, Oskar Schönfelder und solche Sachen. Und jetzt fällt Oskar Schönfelder nach einem bösen Fall wieder weg. War das nicht sogar gegen Elversberg? Nein, das war früher. Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht mehr. Der sich wieder am Knie schwer verletzt hat. Und jetzt hast du nur noch Brian Hain. Ich will nicht auf Brian Hain drauf fahren, weil er sich stark gesteigert hat. Er hat das immer besser angenommen, er hat das gut adaptiert. Aber nichtsdestotrotz hast du jetzt nur noch Brian Hain. Was ist, wenn mit dem was ist? Oder wenn er mal in eine Formkrise wiederkommt. Dann eben in der Offensive haben viele Leute geholt. Christian Kühlwetter, der keine Spielpraxis hatte ewig, der zwar schon zeigt, dass er es kann, aber irgendwo platzt der Knoten nicht. Und man merkt halt einfach, dass irgendwo man sagt das immer so mit einem lachenden Auge, das Telefonbuch von Achim Beierlotz anscheinend ziemlich leer ist, weil er anscheinend niemanden kennt, wo wir uns was leihen können. Dass man mal bei Beiern fragt, habt ihr wen, den ihr uns leihen könntet, so nach dem Motto. Das redet sich aber halt immer alles so leicht. Das ist das Problem, wo ich mit viele dieser Kritik an den ganzen Sachen habe, weil Vivo spielen kann ich auch. Das war halt leider nicht das echte Leben. Also wir haben Bedarf, wir brauchen einen Außenverteidiger, definitiv, eventuell noch mal einen Sturm. Aber ich denke, wir müssen damit leihen arbeiten und schauen, was wir bekommen. Und nochmal, der Jahn hat schon ein bisschen Geld, aber ich denke nicht, dass der Jahn in der Position ist, sich fertige, ich nenne es jetzt mal Produkte, Entschuldigung für den Ausdruck, Produkte zu kaufen. Wir können jetzt nicht losziehen und sagen, hey, wir holen uns jetzt ein, wie hat euer Außenverteidiger geheißen Baum, Baum, Braun?
Baum ist geliehen von Freiburg, von Frankfurt, Entschuldigung.
Als blöds Beispiel, wir können jetzt nicht hergehen und sagen, hey, Frankfurt, beenden wir mal die Laie mit Elversberg, wir kaufen uns jetzt einen Baum. In der Lage sind wir nicht. Wir könnten aber fragen, hey, Frankfurt, habt ihr vielleicht noch einen Verteidiger, den ihr uns leihen könntet, der aber halt dann Zeit braucht, sich zu entwickeln. Und ich denke, das ist halt auch die Idee hinter Andi Patz. Also tun wir nichts weg, es wird sehr kritisch gesehen, weil er hat natürlich unter Enok schon gearbeitet, also was soll sich großartig ändern. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es eben das, was viele immer fordern, eine interessante Alternative. Klar wäre es vielleicht schöner gewesen, wenn du eine andere interessante Alternative gehabt hättest und Andi noch mal ins zweite Klick getreten wäre, um zu lernen und vielleicht damals zu übernehmen. Aber du musst halt schauen, was du kriegst, was sich entwickelt. Und das ist, also wie gesagt Außenverteidiger, eventuell findest du in der Offensive welche, wo du eher abgeben kannst oder verleihen kannst, dass sie sich vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt machen können. Ansonsten eine große Kritik von mir, die ich schon damals hatte, ist Rebuild 2025. Heutzutage gibt es ja anscheinend nur noch 2-Jahres-Verträge. Das ist jetzt anscheinend meine FIFA-Welt gewesen persönlich, weil ich hätte immer längere Verträge gemacht. Bei uns laufen 2025 wieder alle Verträge aus. Also wenn wir auch absteigen, ich glaube dann gehen wieder 10 Leute. Und da musst du halt auch schauen, wen willst du vielleicht behalten, wen willst du nicht behalten. Also das ist halt auch ein schwieriges Thema. Und wie gesagt, dann der Stürrhoch dann auch in Bayer-Lorz in seiner ersten Sportdirektor-Position. Der halt auch lernen muss. Und da bist du halt jetzt die Frage, willst du ihm die Zeit geben und lernen lassen? Wo jetzt ich persönlich schon ein Fan davon bin, aber ich kann auch viele kritische Stimmen verstehen. Ich sage, Fußball ist Ergebnis-Sport, Fußball ist Erfolg, es muss erfolgreich sein und die Zeit gibt man ihm nicht. Na dann muss man halt auch wieder sagen, dann haben wir den vierten Sportdirektor innerhalb seit zwei Jahren, seitdem Christian Köhler weg ist.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, da muss man sich schon entscheiden mit NLZ oder wenn man auf Teufel kommt raus vielleicht die Klasse halten. Und jetzt, also zehn Spieler wären vielleicht weg, wenn man absteigt. Wie groß wäre denn die Katastrophe, wenn man jetzt absteigen würde? Also was würden denn das für Regensburg und für den Verein bedeuten?
Das ist eben das, wo ich gesagt habe, dass wir in so einer guten Lage sind. Wir würden nicht untergehen. Wir würden jetzt nicht in Fahrwasser gekommen. Da muss mich Eva bitte korrigieren, wenn ich sage, wie es bei Bielefeld anscheinend damals war, als es so schlimm ausgeschaut hat. Oder bei Duisburg oder mit 60 oder so. Das auf gar keinen Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall. Natürlich profitieren wir davon ein bisschen vom städtischen Stadion, das im Schwarzbuch der bunte Steuerzahler war. Und der FDP-Stadtrat regt sich immer noch auf.
Kann ja mal eine Pyramide basteln.
Nein, aber wir würden es überleben. Eventuell müssten wir wieder Einsprachungen machen. Also vielleicht, dass das eine Videoanalyse, der Oli Seitz für euch vielleicht wieder gehen müsste, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Aber wir würden definitiv klar kommen. Wir dürfen natürlich auch nicht zu lange bleiben, weil das natürlich den Bau des NHZs immer weiter nach hinten schiebt. Darum ist ja der DFB-Pokal für uns so ein Segen. Um einmal die Finanzen von Regensburg ganz einfach darzustellen, nehmen wir uns unseren Jugend-Spieler, den Pauli Wurm, weil er so gute Leistungen bringt. Dann sagt Elversberg, den will ich. Dann sagt er, wir bieten euch eine Million. Dann sagt der Jan, nimm Pauli Wurm, unser NHZ ist bezahlt. Passt. So sind unsere Finanzen. Das hört sich jetzt an, als wären wir die ärmsten Kirchenmäuse. Das nicht. Aber dann hätten wir heute unser Ziel so erreicht. Wir könnten das finanzieren und hätten vielleicht nur was übrig. So. Einfach sehr konservativ wahrscheinlich.
Eine Million bis NHZ-Finanzierung ist jetzt auch nicht so viel. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel hier in Bielefeld, da sollte es auch wahnsinnig lange neues NHZ geben. Und im Endeffekt hat man es eben mit der Hilfe von Goldberg hier geschafft. Also einem lokalen Unternehmer, der hat halt das NHZ jetzt gebaut. Und ich meine, wenn man es vergleicht, Bielefeld hat zwischenzeitlich zwei Jahre Bundesliga gespielt, lange vorher, oder zweite Liga. Also es ist eben, um einfach zu unterstreichen, eben gerade in der NHL, also in Bielefeld gibt es immer noch keine U23-Mannschaft, weil es einfach extrem teuer ist, sowas auf Dauer zu finanzieren. Und das sind natürlich so verschiedene Dinge, die einander dann auch bedingen. Also wenn bei dir immer ab der U19 Schluss ist, um auch eben jüngere Spieler auszubilden oder irgendwie das für dich attraktiv zu machen, dann ist natürlich auch etwas schwierig. Und ich glaube dahingehend, dass das schon, ja, ist ein schwieriger Weg. Aber ja, also ich wüsste es jetzt auch nicht. Also ich glaube, ich bin generell einfach kein großer Arjen-Bayer-Lorz-Affent. Ich weiß nicht, war ich nie. Aber ja, klar, also ich meine, man muss ja auch sagen, wahrscheinlich eine Finanz-, also beziehungsweise Präsidium, ich weiß nicht genau, wie es bei euch strukturiert ist. Aber wer immer auch gesagt hat, hier, Bayer-Lorz, er soll den Job machen. Ich meine, also wenn ich jemanden einstelle, wo ich weiß, er hat noch keine Erfahrung, dann muss ich natürlich aber auch überlegen, was mache ich denn jetzt? Also dass das jetzt keine einfachen Jahre werden auch oder Monate auch, muss einem dann ja auch bewusst sein. Also da ist ja dann immer die Frage, welchen Weg wollten wir auch mit Bayer-Lorz gehen?
Hast du dich mit Max vorher unterhalten?
Nein.
Sicher? Weil Max ist auch ein großer Kritiker unseres Präsidenten. Zu Recht, weil ich meine, das Präsidium muss sich ja vorwerfen lassen, hey, ihr habt vor Bayer-Lorz zwei nicht erfolgreiche Sportdirektoren gehabt und jetzt wieder eventuell ein nicht erfolgreiches. Was ist da los? Ich meine, beim Jahn ist es übrigens, ich glaube, das ist auch ganz interessant, weil ich gerade nochmal nachschau, auf den Pfarreien gehören 90 Prozent vom Jahn, 10 Prozent sind der Rest, wobei ich da eine witzige Anekdote noch einstreuen kann. In Regensburg gab es ja die Spendenaffäre, wer das mal will, kann das mal nachlesen. Und dieser Bauträger, der die Teile gehabt hat, hat das an einen Investor verkauft und dieser Investor, der hat mich meine damalige Vollgesetze in meiner Arbeit angesprochen, die hatte ein Haus, wollte das verkaufen, der wollte das kaufen. Der wirkt aber nicht sehr seriös, ich habe gesagt, ja, lassen sie es bleiben, das ist beim Jahn auch nicht sehr seriös. Wenn man die Fans protestiert, dann muss der das wieder zurückverkaufen. Also so ist das alles ein bisschen zustande gekommen. Meines Präsidiums muss ich natürlich auch Fragen gefallen lassen. Ich denke, was beim Jahn jetzt wieder so, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll, das ist jetzt vielleicht sehr einfacher, das mit sehr vielen Klischees gesagt, aber ich meine, wir sind heute hier in der Oberpfalz. Regensburg ist schon eine große Stadt, eine bekannte große Stadt, eine schöne große Stadt, aber es ist halt kein Bielefeld, kein Dortmund oder Berlin, wo du halt immer mal wieder irgendwelche Leute hast.
Die Dürraufzählung von Staunen.
Ich soll euch nicht sagen, wir sind halt irgendwo in der Pampa. Wir sind schon, Regensburg ist schon groß, aber da hast du halt drumherum nichts. Ich glaube, der Jonas kann da schon ganz gut mit. Du hast halt im Saarland, da kommt halt erst einmal lange nichts Großes, wo du irgendwo draus ziehen kannst. Das gute Beispiel ist das NSZ, das ist schon wichtig. Das Problem bei unseren Jugendmannschaften, unsere U21 zum Beispiel, ist, die spielen in der Bayernliga. Das heißt, selbst wenn du ein Talent hast, dann musst du in der Bayernliga spielen. Nicht mal in der Regionalliga Bayern, die ja auch nicht gut ist. So im Vergleich zur Regionalliga West-Südwest und solche Sachen. Und ich glaube, da hast du schon so ein bisschen Probleme. Woher kommen halt diese Kontakte? Du merkst halt meiner Meinung nach immer noch, dass der Jan halt einfach klein ist, dass das ganze Umfeld klein ist, dass wir halt auch jahrelang in der Versenkung verschwunden waren, bevor wir damals wieder hochgekommen sind. Das kann dir halt als Miniapide-Feld, die schon Jahrzehnte oben waren, nicht so einfach passieren. Also nicht, sollte man meinen, ne? Und das ist halt etwas, und ich glaube, das ist halt beim Jahr war lange Weg eben auch gescheiterte, in dicken Anführungszeichen-Spieler, also mit einem Karriereknick oder heute junge Regionalliga-Spieler zu verpflichten. Aber man sieht ja, dass das mittlerweile noch mehr machen, wie sonst, und das ist natürlich dann für ein Jahr hart, ich meine, woher willst du da andere ausstechen? Und wie gesagt, das ist, was diesem ganzen, denke ich, diesen Prozess gehört, dass man sich jetzt mal bewusst werden will, wo will man jetzt, also man weiß schon, wo man hin will, man will in diesen Top-Fereien bleiben, man würde gerne auf lange Sicht länger wieder in der 2. Liga bleiben, oder zumindest im oberen Feld vor der 3. Liga erstmal und dann wieder in die 2. Liga und ja, wir sind schon noch vollgesunken, wir wollen wirklich dauerhaft in der 2. Liga bleiben, bloß du musst halt schauen, was du halt aufholen musst, was du für Konkurrenz hast und ja, wie einfach, das ist halt, ich kann es immer nur wieder sagen, das ist nicht so alles, wie man sich das im Fußballmanager vorstellt. Es hört sich blöd an, aber es ist halt so.
Ja. Morgen, Abend oder je nachdem, wenn ihr das hört, vielleicht auch heute Abend schon, geht es dann im DFB-Pokal gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Ist vielleicht einfach mal ein Spiel, wo man, also, sind wir mal ganz realistisch. Pokal hat seine eigenen Gesetze, ich weiß.
Ja, nächstes Jahr heute Europa.
Ja, genau.
Das verstehe ich, frage ich nicht.
Gibt es ja, ist natürlich in den VfB Stuttgart schon nochmal ein anderes Kliber als der VfL Bruchum. Ist einfach so. Aber es, also vielleicht tut es einfach der, also sowohl der Jahn-Säle mal ganz gut, als auch sämtlichen Spielern einfach mal so. Also ich meine, mal gerade eben ins DFB-Pokal, Achtelfinale, kommst halt trotzdem nicht. Und das ist natürlich vielleicht einfach für den Kopf. Ja, eine schöne Sache, wenn du es irgendwie schaffst, zumindest 45 Minuten ganz gut dagegen zu stehen.
Nein, man probiert es. Einfach probieren.
Eben. Und dann geht es jetzt eben am Wochenende gegen Köln, dann ausser jetzt gegen den KSC. Und dann ist das letzte Spiel des Jahres gegen Darmstadt. Auch buntes Potpourri, ehrlich gesagt. Zwei Mal Top 10 dabei. Stand jetzt. Aber, ja, also ich glaube halt wirklich, wir haben, wie gesagt, bei Eintracht Frankfurt, Eintracht Braunschweig, Junge, Junge, Junge, letzte Saison gesehen, dass eben ein, zwei wichtige Entscheidungen im Winter und dann eben gut rauskommen aus dieser Winterpause unfassbar wichtig sein können. Und jetzt eben, es ist eben nochmal eine andere Situation als in der letzten Saison. Und da ist definitiv ja noch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen. Man hat eben den direkten Kontakt und bei einem, eben unter anderem bei einem Schalke 04 und bei einem Führer, da brennt der Baum vielleicht mal ein bisschen früher als…
Wie gesagt, das ist halt, also erstmal mal kurz zum Spiel gegen Stuttgart. Das ist natürlich für viele von der Fanszene, vor allem von der organisierten Fanszene ein tolles Spiel, weil man hat hier eine Fan-Vorschaft mit dem Stuttgarter Kickers. Das ist also, das denke ich, ganz spannend. Ansonsten… Nein, ich überlege gerade, wie ich das sage. Es ist einfach… Ja, es ist schwierig, weil… Vielleicht zeichnet das auch irgendetwas ab einem gewissen Punkt einen Jahn-Fan aus, weil man sich einfach damit abgebunden hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist so, man hat doch gewusst, worauf es hinsteuert. Man hat sich halt mehr erhofft. Und wie gesagt, ich kann es nur noch mal sagen, wenn du noch mehr so Spiele hast wie gegen Nürnberg oder gegen Fürth das erste Mal, oder auch mal wieder so blöde Spiele wie gegen Schalke, wo du halt einfach überhaupt nicht richtig mitgemacht hast, dann brennt bei uns auch der Baum. Also dann ist definitiv wie sowas gegen Braunschweig… Man kann doch darauf aufbauen. Ich meine, viele haben sich schon ein bisschen damit abgefunden, aber es geht halt einfach auch gut darum, sich zu präsentieren. Und ich bin immer noch die Überzeugung, wenn du es halt nochmal schaffst, dich einfach ein bisschen aufzubäumen und diese Probleme nach und nach zu lösen, dann kannst du noch irgendwie dranbleiben. Und das geht halt. Du musst halt dranbleiben. Wenn natürlich jetzt Münster morgen Lauf hat und dann Ullmann läuft, dann haben wir ein Problem. Aber warum sollten die auf einmal so viel mehr in Lauf haben? Die spielen ab und an schöner Fußball, ja. Aber ich bin einfach kein Fan davon, das jetzt halt einfach nur bis zum Saisonende abzuschreiben. Man muss einfach kämpfen, Gas geben. Wie gesagt, wir haben gewusst, worauf es vor der Saison hinausläuft. Und was wären wir für ein Zweitligist, wenn wir es nicht wenigstens versuchen würden, anzunehmen? Aber man muss halt so realistisch bleiben. Wir haben ein Problem, für alle. Wir müssen viel arbeiten. Wir müssen noch viel Lehrgeld zahlen. Es ist auch spannend zu sehen, wie es weitergeht. Und dann muss man auf die nächste Saison blicken. Und ich will es halt nicht abschreiben. So jetzt, wir haben noch, welcher Spieltag war jetzt der? Spieltag, jetzt haben wir einen 15. Spieltag. Wir haben noch eine ganze Rückrunde. Wer weiß, vielleicht holen wir im Winter den Außenverteidiger, der von der Mittellinie dauernd Tor ist. Das tut er nicht wirklich. Ich weiß, dass er nicht.
Bitte, bitte, bitte nicht den Außenverteidiger aus Bielefeld tun und holen, der das wirklich kann.
Wie heißt denn der Name?
Der Luis Abhi, bitte nicht tun.
Nee, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich denke nicht, dass wir höher als 16 kommen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass wir direkt wieder runtergehen. Aber ich weigere mich aufzugeben. Das möchte ich nicht. Ich möchte, dass sie kämpfen. Das war schon immer ein Jahnmarkenzeichen bis zum Ende. Ich möchte auch, dass wir lernen und dass wir nicht einfach nur Kurzschlussreaktionen treffen. Ich glaube, das habe ich auch ein bisschen von Elversberg herausgehört. Da werden auch eine Kurzschlussreaktion getroffen, als wir damals in der Regionalliga rumgetümpelt sind. Da haben wir gesagt, okay, pass auf. So ist der Plan, wie Heidenheim oder Freiburg was gemacht haben. Man hat ja gesehen, dass es bisher funktioniert, wie es funktioniert hatte. Man muss halt was ändern, man muss halt dem Ganzen eine Chance geben und dann wird man sehen.
Das ist halt gerade der Pokal. Der kann ja auch schon vielleicht ein bisschen was freisetzen. Also ich weiß, vor zwei Jahren in der dritten Liga, da haben wir das Pokalspiel gegen Leverkusen gehabt. Das haben wir mit 4 zu 3 gewonnen und das war dann auch wieder so ein, für die dritte Liga. Und ich meine, das war damals eins, wenn nicht sogar das letzte Spiel von St. Joanne in Leverkusen. Das heißt, so gesehen haben wir den Leverkusenern den Meistertitel erst möglich gemacht. Dafür bekamen wir bis jetzt noch nicht mal einen Dankeschön.
Aber naja, und da war ja auch die volle Schuld, dass ich nicht mehr ansehen muss.
Das ist, der Alonso muss noch mal vorbeikommen und sagen, er leidet vielleicht immer ein, zwei Trainings.
Zumindest die Karte wäre doch nett.
Ich denke mir halt einfach am Ende vom Tag immer so, ich sag, klar, man muss irgendwo realistisch bleiben. Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, wie du es schon so gesagt hast, bei Elversberg war es ja genauso, jetzt stell dir mal vor, wir machen im Dezember, aus welchem Grund auch immer, gewinnen wir jetzt gegen Köln und von mir aus gegen Darmstadt, das ist ein blödes Beispiel. Und die anderen beiden spielen so weiter wie bisher. Ja, dann warst du vielleicht schon mal nicht mehr Letzter. Und du weißt ja nicht, was das dann halt ausmacht. Darum, klar, realistisch gesehen gewinnen wir kein einziges. Vielleicht gegen Darmstadt und Unentschieden. Aber ich stelle mir halt einfach vor, wenn ich jetzt Spieler wäre und würde mitbekommen, dass meine Fans grundsätzlich so denken, fände ich das blöd. Und das ist halt einfach nicht meine Einstellung dazu. Und das erwarte ich ja nicht von der Mannschaft. Ich erwarte ja von der Mannschaft, dass sie nicht aufgibt, dass sie kämpft. Da muss ich als Fan, der ich ja am Ende auch nur bin, auch machen. Auch wenn wir, wie gesagt, viele Problemfelder haben und viel zu lösen haben. Und wir werden sehen, wo es hingeht. Wie du auch in Bayer-Lotze geschaut hast, er ist nicht hundertprozentig umstritten. Aus diversen Gründen und seinen diversen Auftritten. Ich denke, er ist immer noch ein Fußballfachmann, aber in gewissen Punkten muss er sich definitiv ändern. Rest wirst du sehen.
Gut, dann würde ich an der Stelle mal sagen, ich habe euch natürlich eine sehr optimistische Zeitangabe für diese Folge gegeben. Ich entschuldige mich, aber es ist auch ein gutes Zeichen, dass wir viel zu bereden hatten. Und von daher will ich es jetzt nach hinten raus. Ich muss es tatsächlich relativ kurz machen. Und euch beiden einfach danken, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Danke Jonas. Schön, dass du uns wieder was zur SVI erzählt hast.
Gar nicht. Komm auch nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ja, und Thomas, ich hoffe, wir hören uns dann nächstes Jahr auch nochmal.
Irgendwas mit Bidefett bestimmt.
Und dann was? Wünsche ich euch schon mal eine schöne Adventszeit noch. Ich glaube, ihr hört mich in diesem Jahr nicht mehr. Schöne Weihnachten an alle, die es feiern. Wir hören uns im neuen Jahr wieder. Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.